okay next question is for greg it's from
fictional funkness
could you discuss the relationship
between training frequency and
recoverable
volume spreading work across more
sessions seems as if it would allow more
to be done
but is a minimum volume per session
necessary to get sufficient
stimulus yeah so that's a good question
and i think i'm going to address it
in reverse so the first the first
question i'm going to address
is is there a minimum volume per session
necessary to get in sufficient volume to
to have
like a meaningful stimulus and
as far as that goes like i don't think
we know for sure
at least i'm not aware of any convincing
evidence that
volume in a session can be too low to
you know have some sort of positive
beneficial effect
so i mean so there was a
um the the meta-analysis that most
people refer to now
as it pertains to training volume and
the effects on hypertrophy
uh was by showing schoenfeld and
colleagues published
i think last year i think it was 2018.
and and so it was looking at volume
per week so number of training sets per
week and that's the one most people have
top of mind that's the one that you see
most people
discussing on social media when the
topic of volume comes up
but back in i believe 2010
uh there was another meta-analysis like
the the prior one on volume that used to
be the one that everyone would cite
by james krieger
and i think that may have actually been
his first publication ever
uh he did one on strength and one on
hypertrophy
and and that was back at a time in the
industry when
like the the hit crowd like the high
intensity training
one set to failure is all you need crowd
was like really resurgent within the
industry
um and so what james did is basically go
through all of the studies
looking at a single set versus multi-set
resistance training and the effects on
hypertrophy
and strength so two different
meta-analyses and
uh for both of them single-set training
did have a positive effect but it wasn't
as large as multi-set training
so i think for both of those metas um
he looked at single set training and
then he looked at
uh like two to four sets and then he
looked at
five to six sets and then there wasn't
anything above six sets
um that was included in his meta
but anyway so in in both of those cases
single set training
did seem to have positive effects for
both strength and hypertrophy
so i don't think i i don't think we can
say that there's like
assuming training is like to failure or
close to failure like just one set
is still probably going to do something
beneficial
if that's something that concerns you
though
i would say at minimum if you're doing
like three or four working sets like
that's definitely gonna do something for
you
um maybe like the optimal volume for you
in a session would be slightly higher
than that but
like three or four sets is going to be a
very very safe
level of per session volume that is
going to do something beneficial for you
um so then then that brings up the
question of frequency
and whether higher frequencies allow
higher
weekly training volumes and just how
that interacts with
everything so first off
one thing we need to keep in mind is
that
[Music]
actually no i'm getting ahead of myself
so
okay the basic question of does higher
frequency allow you to tolerate higher
weekly volumes
i don't think there's any direct
research looking at that but i think
like
logically the answer is absolutely yes
uh
at least to some degree so for example
if we compared
you know working out once per week for a
given muscle group
to three times per week or something
if you want to do squats doing five sets
of squats three times a week
that's gonna be kind of hard but it's
not gonna be bad
doing 15 hard sets of squats in a single
workout is gonna [ __ ] suck
um i would very much not recommend you
do that and
you know you're probably well past the
point of diminishing returns for
what you can get out of that one workout
by the time you get up to 15 sets for a
single muscle
so i i think it's a little
more hazy when you when you start
talking about like
higher frequencies compared to higher
yet frequencies
so you know i think if you're training a
particular muscle three or four times
per week
you're probably going to be able to get
in more volume than if you're
you know just training that muscle one
to two times per week
but in terms of like high quality volume
is like five or six times per week
going to let you do that much more than
three or four times per week
uh who knows i i think i think that is a
little bit hazier but
yeah certainly you know having higher
higher frequencies to a point is going
to allow you to do
more high quality volume per muscle
group
one consideration to keep in mind though
is there's some
evidence suggesting that um
if you do full body workouts it may lead
to
like a smaller hypertrophic effect for
each of the muscles trained
than if the workout like just focused on
that particular muscle
so that's coming from uh three studies
looking at um
looking at the effects of protein
supplementation on muscle protein
synthesis
of the quads um and so
two of them just looked at different
protein doses
only doing quad training and then the
third and most recent one
looked at uh like a full body workout
but still just looking at muscle protein
synthesis in the quads
and the the volume of training for the
quads and the protein dosages were the
same in the third study as the first
two studies but the the total level of
muscle protein synthesis was like
30 percent lower give or take which
led the authors to speculate and then
people discussing the study on social
media to speculate
that um you know if if you're training
more muscle groups
within a given training session like the
overall protein synthetic response for
each muscle group you train
may be a little bit lower than if it was
a training session
just focused on one single muscle group
so
like on one hand will higher frequencies
allow you
to train with higher weekly volumes yes
absolutely
but then two you know higher frequencies
are going to require you to train
more muscle groups in a particular
session and do more full body workouts
so maybe like that also requires higher
volumes to have the same
effect on a per muscle per workout basis
if that makes sense
so so i think that i think that overall
the research does lean in favor
of higher higher frequencies allowing
for higher volumes
and then that higher volume probably
improving
hypertrophy and strength outcomes to
some extent but i don't think
the extent to which that occurs would be
as much
as one would assume just looking at the
amount of
increase in volume you get so for
example if you can say
increase your weekly volume 50
by increasing your frequency that's not
going to lead to
50 more hypertrophy 50 larger strength
gains
it may be better but it may mean like
you know 20
more hypertrophy 20 larger strength
gains
um so yeah i don't think that was a
pretty
or particularly well organized response
but i i think
i think i got everything out there that
i wanted to
i think so okay people can put it back
together in whatever order they choose
fair enough